Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 12th episode!
BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
But because there might be some new Ruffians joining us for the first time today, to explain FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, by us, FUWAMOCO.
In case you didn't know!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start off your day on the right paw.
Please make sure you tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, BAU BAU!
Now, first, we have something a bit important to talk about, okay?
Listen closely, okay?
We have an apology.
Very important apology.
We want to apologize to any Ruffians who are deeply disturbed, even maybe traumatized, by our previous episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
It aired last week.
Do you remember it?
Oh, you do?
Unfortunately, there was an on-air incident where instead of us being here to run the show, our pet petal took over.
Yeah, it was a pretty serious on-air incident.
We're sorry.
We're sorry, Ruffians.
If you felt uncomfortable, or bad, or even worse, if he hurt your smile.
He wasn't rude, right?
Are you okay, Ruffians?
You're deeply traumatized!
He didn't scare you, right?
He said he would beat you up!
He was adorable.
Those are very different messages just now.
Just a bit conflicting.
A little bit.
Anything scary?
Did he say anything scary?
Your smile was damaged!
No... No...
We're really, really sorry.
We'll make sure that we teach him some new tricks once we get our paws on him, okay?
Yeah.
He'll get back here eventually.
Eventually.
We'll find him, right?
Yeah.
But... Yeah, we're not really sure what's going on.
We thought he was still in the background.
Right!
We weren't looking.
Yeah, we weren't able to rescue him, but... Maybe not.
Yeah...
We're sorry, Ruffians.
Please, please, our sincerest apologies.
We won't sleep in again, okay?
Yeah.
It's so weird.
Onto our normal stuff.
Actually, Moco-chan, it seems like another Ruffian has seen Perroccino.
Where is he now?
He just keeps on going.
What?
I guess he's still not stuck in the back rooms.
Maybe not.
Well, this Ruffian reported seeing him at their workplace.
I guess...
Maybe Pero got bored of his day to day and decided to get some good life experience.
Maybe that's why he's not around recently.
He wants to branch out.
Maybe, maybe.
I definitely never knew he was forklift certified.
Maybe he studied up and passed a test while he was stuck in the backgrounds or something.
Wow.
That would be good.
I'd be happy.
I wonder how he... he... he pushes all the pedals and the wheels.
Let's not think too deeply about it.
Yeah.
But why did he learn... Why did he want to learn how to drive a forklift?
Why not get new skills?
True.
I mean, they're yellow.
It's kind of like a cart, but it makes beep beep beep sounds, right?
That's kind of fun.
It's sort of fun.
Yeah, you know?
Pick up stuff.
Or maybe, you know... Drop stuff.
Drop stuff.
Maybe he did it to help this Ruffian out.
Are there any other Ruffians that would like Pero to come help them out with his forklift?
I think that sounds good.
Do you need some forklift help, Ruffians?
Beep beep sounds yes.
It's a big part of the job.
Yes!
Nah, you're good.
You're good?
Okay.
Can you do your work too?
A little bit maybe, but... You probably do the work the best.
That's a very interesting sighting today, right?
Please, Ruffians, let us know if you see him around again.
Maybe he'll be at your workplace next?
Yeah, can you use him as a cushion?
I think so.
Maybe, yeah.
Yeah, just wash him real good.
If you do happen to see him, remember to use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Okay, okay.
You know, actually, you know, it is really strange that Pero would be driving a forklift, but maybe he was inspired by us, you know, with our new job to pick up new smiles.
Now, Pero wanted to get a job too.
Maybe.
Maybe?
But I don't think he's that... I want to assume the best.
Yeah, okay.
Maybe he's changing a bit, huh?
Maybe.
FUWAMOCO, are we forklift certified?
No.
I cannot drive a car.
I think a forklift is included in that.
I think the beep beep part is fun though.
The beep beep, right?
And the dropping stuff.
That's cool.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Well, we have some exciting news!
There's a lot of things that happened over this weekend.
First, Novi-san!
Holo Abyss, Demon of Sound.
Arisa Ravenclaw.
She released her third song cover!
We heard it already!
This time, it's Magia from Mahou Shoujo Madoka Magica.
Amazing!
Ruffians, you know she's the Demon of Sound for a reason.
You heard it?
It was really good, right?
Right!
All the harmonies!
And the visuals too!
If you haven't had a chance yet, go!
After FUWAMOCO Morning.
Go check it out.
Do you have a favorite part, Ruffians?
I think, for me, my favorite part was the bridge leading into the final chorus.
You know, everything like, picks up and gets so intense.
I kinda got... I got goosebumps.
It was a bit nostalgic too though, right?
It's really the perfect song for New Year's.
Please go give a listen, okay Ruffians?
After FUWAMOCO Morning.
And what else do we have?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Did you see?
We actually have some extra special photos here that you might have not seen yet.
See?
Look it!
Oh, you got them!
Oh!
Well, you know... In case you needed a bit more convincing.
Yeah.
Here are the magnets too!
We're really looking forward to them, you know.
They're such a good size.
They're nice and thick.
Nice and thick, you know.
If you happen to accidentally hit them off the fridge, like sometimes I do, they won't break apart!
Yeah!
They look very strong.
I have a bit of a habit of doing this.
Yeah, the magnets before.
And the acrylic stands here.
And we have this stained glass kitchen.
It's very appealing.
Are there any Ruffians?
Have you decided where you're gonna put it?
It'd be nice outside in the summer, right?
True, true.
You know, it'd kind of be nice to get a bird feeder, plant some flowers, and then put this up near it.
You know, I sort of feel like it'd be a good present to give your mom.
To Mama Puppy?
I'm sure Mama Puppy would like it too, but I'm sure Ruffian Mama.
Maybe we should order multiple copies?
I guess Mother's Day is a bit far away, but you could save it for later.
Start thinking now!
And of course, the debut merch wouldn't be complete without the acrylic stands too.
If you order Moco-chan's acrylic stand,
It'd be nice if you could order my stand too.
Right?
You will, right?
It's a pair, right?
Moco-chan, you don't want to be separated?
No, not really.
Please!
Why?
Important though.
This is the important part.
The photos are very pretty, but...
The pre-order window ends in a week from today, so please be sure to order yours before it closes, okay?
Yeah, okay!
Debut merch only happens once.
Now is the chance!
Also check out our starting voice packs too!
There's a lot of volume.
A lot of volume?
Volume, you know.
You think it's just like a morning voice being like, good morning.
But it's actually much more than that.
Please check it out!
BAU BAU!
Don't forget!
Only one week left until you can't get them anymore.
You already got them?
Thank you!
Actually, there's also something very exciting about this weekend.
It was holo-summer.
Yes, this past weekend was the grand finale of this year's holo-summer.
Ruffians, you might have joined us for a much longer splash party.
Did you enjoy it?
Also, did you know that Advent week got to participate in Holo Summer in another way too?
Yeah!
Did you see them?
Did you see?
Ruffians!
Yes!
De-den!
We participated in the Holo Summer Shorts Series!
What did you think?
Did you enjoy them?
Did you like my cotton candy?
Did you like splashing?
Splashing with Moco-chan!
We had a lot of fun recording them, so we hope that you'll check them out.
You can find them right on our YouTube channel here too.
Only after FUWAMOCO Morning.
Only after, of course.
They're short, you know, so... Why was the cotton candy crunchy?
Because it's special.
Did you know that when cotton candy, the best way to eat it is when you crush it down and sort of make it all...
Like a sandwich.
And then it's extra crunchy.
That's why it sounds crunchy.
But I wanted to say though, especially maybe for the Ruffians that
Visual Novels have a special place in our hearts.
Definitely check it out, because there's a lot of Visual Novel vibes to them too.
I think, you know, hopefully next year things might be a little different, but we're just really really happy to be given the opportunity to participate.
I didn't expect that, right Mococo?
I'm happy.
Ruffians, did you have a favorite part?
At least for me, my favorite part was when I go, hey, hey, hey!
You know?
What about you, Moco-chan?
Oh, I liked it when the water splashed before me.
It was really nice and refreshing, you know?
Yeah.
It felt like, yes, this is whole summer, right?
Yeah, yeah.
FUWAMOCO Vision of When.
One day.
Hopefully.
It's one of our goals!
We can't synchronize saying that.
But for now, maybe this will have to be the start of that.
Please take a peek at the Mocchi and Abyss!
Check it out!
Awesome!
In case you didn't know,
Our membership!
They opened this weekend!
So not only was it holo summer ground finale, but it was extra extra special because not only, you know, it was our 500k celebration, but our membership also opened!
Thank you so so much for all your love, Ruffians.
We're so happy to form the strong Doggy Pack all together now.
Doggy Pack, Doggy Pack, alright?
And I think some Ruffians have been enjoying all the special emotes.
Maybe just a bit.
I don't see lots of BAU BAUs.
No, not at all.
Thank you for the BAU BAUs!
Yeah, our emotes were illustrated by Meru-pun-san.
Meru-pun-san, arigatou!
So cute!
They're so, so cute.
We almost died of cuteness when we first saw them.
Please continue to give us lots and lots, okay?
We also hope that we can add even more emotes in the future, so let's build a more passionate, a more strong Doggy Pack, okay?
We also have some fun plans coming up for the Doggy Pack very soon, so if you're thinking of joining, it might be a good time.
And be like, let's do this!
That was the first thing you said before you said good morning or anything.
Get out of bed, Fuwawa.
You're like, this, this, this.
What do you think of this?
I was kind of like, what are you talking about?
I feel like that's a good time for ideas for me.
Right when I wake up.
Let's do... Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Doggy pack, doggy pack, doggy pack.
You know, we talked about some lighter topics, more celebratory topics and happy things, but we have a misunderstanding.
This one's kind of heavy.
Yeah.
I don't know anything.
Moco-chan.
Well, during our Splash Party Day 1 What's Along With Avin, which kind of turned into a very happy, mostly happy chit-chatting collab stream.
Moco-chan, this girl here.
Oh, me?
Yeah, you.
Kind of said something very out of character.
Was it?
Yeah, it was.
Do you know what it was, Ruffians?
Did it take you off guard just as much as it did me?
So, I was talking about how before I move on from this world, I would like to see actual fireflies.
But I think a lot of Ruffians might have misunderstood it.
And, and, maybe all of Advent also misunderstood it!
Me too!
I'm still sort of confused.
But you know, sometimes I just say things, and they should come out one way, and then they didn't, but I wasn't really listening to what I said, so that's why Fuwawa is here to catch anything strange that I say, but obviously she just wasn't doing her job right, so...
Yeah.
Yeah, it wasn't supposed to be anything dark.
Just that I want to see the fireflies before I move on.
That's all.
I thought, you know, I'd add on because I thought Moco-chan was trying to say something maybe a bit deeper with more of a positive message.
No, I just want to see fireflies.
I added on, you know, that we should be grateful for every summer that we have too, you know, because even though summer feels like it'll be back every
You never really know, right?
So that's why we need to enjoy, you know, our everyday together.
Yeah.
It wasn't supposed to be that deep or anything.
Just a reminder to be grateful for what we have, you know?
Yeah!
But, in other words, Moco-chan, seeing fireflies is on your bucket list, right?
I wanna see fireflies.
Just something simple.
Nothing deep, nothing dark.
You got it!
Misunderstanding... Misunderstanding understood!
Understood?
Understandable.
I just wanna see fireflies.
Yeah.
Understood?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, good.
BAU BAU!
That's good, that's good.
I don't know why you didn't understand to begin with.
It's all their fault.
The way you said it was really scary.
I said nothing weird.
Did you hear the missus' reaction?
She started to talk about snacks instead.
I thought she was just hungry.
She's hungry a lot.
Everybody was like, what?
What?
I don't know.
It is weird.
I felt the air change, though.
Well, on to happier things.
Ruffians!
Our FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle!
You didn't forget about it, right?
Last week, we announced that we're looking for a jingle created by you, Ruffians, for FUWAMOCO Morning.
Do you remember it?
Yeah, the show that's happening right now.
Right now, right here.
We wanted to say a big thank you.
We've already received so many wonderful submissions.
Thank you!
It's gonna be hard to choose just one.
To be honest, I'm not looking forward to that at all.
But we're so happy to see what a creative and fearless bunch you are.
Right?
Fear.
No fear.
Ruffians don't fear anything, especially not making jingles.
And we've seen that there's a lot of newbies that have been submitting their jingles too.
It's perfect.
I'm really happy.
That's exactly what we wanted to see.
You know, let's always do our best to challenge ourselves in new areas too, right?
And I think, you know, there was a few Ruffians wondering where exactly we'll be using it during FUWAMOCO Morning.
So we wanted to explain.
It's important.
At the beginning of... The beginning of every episode, right?
You know, once we transition into the studio, it would go right before we say, Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
You know, it's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
That's the thing, you know?
So we would go, beep boop boop boop boop, and then we'd go, Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
That kind of thing, you know?
And play there.
You know, uh...
But it'd be the first thing that all the Ruffians hear in the morning.
It'd be the first thing they show.
That's what we're thinking.
And it can just be like a simple beep-bop.
You know, so please just give it a shot.
You can submit as many times as you like, so if you submit one and you're like, oh, I had an even better idea, go for it!
Yeah, you don't have to overthink.
It's just supposed to be something with you and us.
Yeah, we said up to 10 seconds, but you know it could be much, much shorter.
It could be 1 second, it could be 2 seconds, it could be 3 seconds, 4 seconds, 5 seconds, 6 seconds, 7 seconds, 8 seconds, 9 seconds, 10 seconds.
That's it.
Serious.
10 seconds.
But, you know, we really want to make FUWAMOCO Morning a show made by us and you.
Bring us all together, you know!
We hope that it can bring us together.
And that this is maybe just another step to do that.
Another step to that.
And as a reminder, I know we have it written here, but submissions close on September 3rd, which is a little less than a week away from now.
Please keep that in mind while you enjoy yourself.
And let's jingle all together happily.
Happy jingling!
Happy jingle!
Moco-chan.
The next thing we have is the time for that time of the day.
I think it is!
It is!
We have... Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
Butters!
Butters has A++ puppy dog eyes.
Big eyes.
It might even be better than eyes.
What do you think, Moco-chan?
Let's see.
BAU BAU.
Moco-chan, you trying?
Head pat.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Nah.
I think Butters does it better.
Can't beat Butters.
Butters loves to make friends with everyone.
Butters is a bit scared of children.
Makes sense.
I get that.
You know, kids can sort of be a bit loud and chaotic.
It can be a bit scary because, you know, sometimes they just want to touch your ears and tails.
So go for it, you know.
No touch!
But Butters also likes to wrestle and play tug-of-war at Ruff House.
A bit tough, a bit soft.
Kinda sounds like you, Moco-chan.
We hope you have lots of fun everyday, Mamas!
How does butter is BAU BAU?
I feel like, you know, maybe butter is smooth but a little bit flurly too.
Flurly BAU BAU?
It's really soft.
That's the buttery part.
That's poppy.
Like a popcorn with butter.
Popcorn with butter BAU.
Butters is a dog who loves to play and be a friend with everyone.
Maybe everyone bigger than her.
Very good tail too.
Right?
Nice tail.
Big ears!
The ears are very cute.
I'm not envious.
The bigger the ears, the bigger the heart.
Are you saying my heart is small?
Yes.
BAU BAU!
That's all it is, huh?
It's still just the morning.
Thank you!
And next for today, I went on a walk!
We have... De-den!
What is this?
Violence.
Did our neighborhood walk turn into something much different?
It looks like you came across...
A food festival and wrestling!
This definitely looks like a good meal.
Can you eat wrestling?
That's cute!
It's pretty cool!
It looks like you had a great time.
I think that's one of the things I love the most about walks is that you can discover really cool things and you never know what you're going to find.
It really brings up your mood.
I just went outside for a walk, but then suddenly everybody's happy!
You know?
Like, sometimes you kind of get stuck in your world, but then when you go out on a walk, then you realize, oh, there's a lot of other worlds going on outside of them.
And then that way you can kind of stretch your paws, change things up a bit.
You know?
It's really refreshing.
It's nice.
You know?
But Moco-chan and I wrestling it out in that window.
I'm the one punching.
No, I'm the one punching.
He looks like he's gonna eat a knuckle sandwich.
It's obvious which one I am.
I don't like sandwiches, so... Well, you know, you never know what you might see when you go outside for a walk.
Maybe one day if you go outside for a walk, you'll find us wrestling it out.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next, for our Question of the Day!
What do we have?
De-den!
Congratulations on reaching over 500,000 people and opening a membership!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
The question is, what is the relationship between FUWAMOCO and Ruffians?
Example, just friends?
Family?
Or...
Oh, this is a good question.
Ruffians, are you curious too?
Nice question, nice question.
Nice question.
Yeah.
What is our relationship?
Very good question.
Well, for us, you're someone very, very, very important and dear to us.
You're someone we look up to.
Someone that we know will be there for us during hard times.
Hopefully.
Hopefully!
Not doubting it, right, Moco-chan?
No, I'm not doubting it.
But friends or family or...
I think you know that's up to you.
I feel like it might be kind of strange of us to just decide that without consulting you first.
It's for you.
So if you think of us as your family or daughters, then we're your daughters.
And if we're best buddies, then best buddies.
And if it's something else, then...
It's a bit embarrassing, but do you understand?
Understood?
Understood!
I don't get it.
Probably like a scary family.
No, more of a happy family.
Happy.
You know.
Understood.
Good.
We're Doggy Pack.
Doggy Pack.
Good, good, good.
That's such a good question though.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And Ruffians, remember.
Gotta remember, we're always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, for Doggie of the Day.
We want to hear more about your works.
Of course, questions too.
Please don't hesitate to submit them.
Use the hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
You might think that they'll never pick up my submissions.
But we have our eyes open.
We have our eyes open.
We're always looking.
We'll be waiting, okay, Ruffians?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
As for our next team... Next up is... Den!
We're playing The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time, but you know, this might be our first evening without going live tonight.
This is actually tomorrow's stream.
We're going to be going back to Haibu.
We just left the Kokiri Village and now we have our Ocarina.
Our journey's just starting, right?
Just the beginning.
We're really really excited to be playing our original game, the game cartridge on our original hardware, the N64.
Do you know what that is?
Probably not.
We started it out last week.
And we felt a bit sad that we couldn't play longer, so this time we want to play more!
We'll also be reading today's Super Chats after this Zelda stream.
The Super Chats from FUWAMOCO Morning today right now will be after Zelda.
As for you know, like I mentioned, this is gonna be our first evening where we're not going live.
So, you know what we feel?
We feel funny, you know?
We're gonna miss you a lot.
But this week, we can focus on getting some of our homeworks done, as well as resting up too.
The things that we have to get done, you know?
But while we're doing that, you know, we thought we'd ask Mama Puppy.
She has a recommended stream for, like a stream archive for Ruffians to watch.
And maybe, Ruffians, could you guess what she recommended?
Just maybe?
Oh?
Well, Mama Puppy... She recommended... De-den!
Our first Arcade of Time.
She really enjoyed it.
It's a game that's very special to all of us, but she'd like it if...
You can watch it.
We like that too.
It's pretty short, so if you weren't able to catch us live, you can watch, catch up, find out just what happened, and then join us tomorrow for the second part.
Mama Puppy thought it was funny that her save data was there too.
So please check it out, okay?
It's pretty bite-sized, I think.
Not as bite-sized as FUWAMOCO Morning, but... Thank you!
And if we take a little peek at our schedule... This week, we're playing some games we've played before and some new games.
We also have our one-month celebration happening on Wednesday.
I know it's kind of funny not being on a weekend, but that's because it's exactly one month to debut.
We're also going to be going back to River City.
We're going to punch, kick, whack our enemies and find boyfriends.
I don't know.
It's a bit of an embarrassing story.
I don't really feel like it represents me.
Moco-chan, do you feel like it represents violence?
I want violence.
But you know, we can show everyone just how strong a team we are.
Please join us!
Thank you!
Hopefully I get better than last time.
I don't know.
I'd like to show some improvement.
I see, I see.
I might have to warm up a little.
Thank you Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Elyos!
BAU BAU!
Maich!
Melays!
BAU BAU!
Togetsu!
Tawan!
BAU BAU!
Lim!
Buta!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!